you know plenty of hot intellectual
humor coming up this episode
that's right that's right there's tons
of serious
intellectual things that we can juggle
about
yeah like panuma like panuma
panumanume
let's talk about it you've done some
research man you got to educate me i was
curious
i wanted to know more okay so if you
don't know what we're talking about
people
there is now a success fda
approved penis enlargement surgery
called panuma and uh
so they use that to market to
millennials in like
a year yeah for panuma yeah it's gonna
be like some
pharma commercial where it's like like
it's gonna be some millennial dude
sitting at his pc
and then he's going to hear the song
he's like what what's that song
so look out the windows and see his
millennial buddy doing the dance
yeah no the dance is the windmill
because they're all windmilling their
new desks oh that's right no they're
flapping it up and down
flapping it up and down and it's going
with their arms
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
miami yeah and then like the dude the
original guy that it started on
it ends on his face going
like oh my god it's the reddit face
it's so buddy you're huge
yeah so panuma is a uh it's a now an fda
approved surgery that people have
so there was an article about this on
where did we see you sent the article
wait wait wait before we get into that
think about the phrase
fda approved
can we really trust that they approved
it
in good conscience like was it just a
guy who came into work that day he's
like
look at his glasses on he's like
wait a second gets the paper out he's
like
okay so you're saying
it's gonna make it bigger yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's uh yeah yeah yeah the first
one's like
what do we got here new supplement cool
yeah
take it on okay new flavor of soda cool
that one's cool
hold up
hey yeah yeah have you
yeah i need to come up to my office take
a look at this
dude comes in he's like we need to fast
track this one
yeah this one need us out by the end of
the month
we need this out this is yeah sir you've
covered it with approval stamps i can't
even read
what it is yeah you know what
it would buy more put this one through
right away but sir the the covid vaccine
we still have the five
what did i just say this one goes in
front
so i'm gonna cover vaccine give me that
cover vaccine they're like
cool now this is that one you're just
gonna put that one on top all right go
ahead
take that just like that
[Laughter]
he's like oh yeah
my time has come finally literally
finally
it's coming yep daddy's
daddy is gonna put that bonus to work
yes he is
so this procedure there was an article
about it in like the la times or or
something like that about how
like doctors have started doing this
it's like it's now approved and
a bunch of people so i was curious right
yeah i'm just
obviously i'm curious you know i don't
want to get it i'm just
curious it's just a little you know a
little kind of sort of
curiosity in my brain i'm like oh let's
do some more research on this right yeah
it could be the podcast dude it could be
fast it could be a great christmas gift
for exactly for someone else yeah
dude merry christmas what is this it's a
ticket to pneuma
i got you panuma wait i got you panuma
oh bro
[Music]
oh
[Music]
why are they so happy they're feeling
larger than life
so i wanted to do some research for the
podcast for you guys
yeah and so i searched it you know
someone's got their [ __ ] ear to the
speaker
hard right now
[Laughter]
go ahead cody hurry up hurry up go ahead
keep going what would you find what'd
you find what'd you find what'd you find
it's a real thing
it's a real thing and many people have
gotten it
it's they shut up cut they cut you open
right like on your bladder area and they
basically insert like a plastic
thing down your shaft and i guess like
the way it works is that like once
you heal the shaft kind of like moves
out of your body and like pushes your
dick
like makes it bigger i think i don't
know i'm not a [ __ ] doctor but that's
the way i
understood it and there's like dudes
like the whole community around it now
of dudes being like wow great results
like post a picture of their dick and
the other one's like
are they were they good results results
what were they good results like did
they
definitely good results befores and
afters i mean it depends right it's like
it's like surgery i mean like anything
can go wrong there's like people that
like lose sensitivity completely there's
people that
lose length which like that imagine that
[ __ ] nightmare you recover from
surgery and your dick's half as big
big hedge seriously that's a
big risk or a small risk
depending but couldn't you just do it
again like if it doesn't take couldn't
you just try again
i don't know that's a good question yeah
because it seems like
every guy yeah could you wait
what's the what's the rate of halfway
half lengthening
and if that doesn't happen how much
length does it i think in most cases it
adds
some girth i think in all cases actually
but
yeah because you're like that's risky
it's basically like you're putting like
a
a hot wheel
chassis on your dick that's what it
looks like
you see you see the chassis of a big
penis
that's what slides into your body it's
like some nascar [ __ ] you know
the actual car underneath the nascar
case
you don't the motor could be smaller it
could be bigger it doesn't matter but on
the outside
it looks like a nascar you know it's
just fiberglass yeah it's just all one
solid piece
yeah yeah yeah it might it might still
perform the same
yeah you know but at least it looks good
mm-hmm
now let me let me it's like a kit car
actually for your penis
now let me ruin everybody's day i think
it costs like eighteen thousand dollars
mm-hmm yeah everybody getting off the
speaker
no no but i read a couple people that
like basically took out loans to do this
which you can also do you can i think
plastic surgery places have like payment
plans
that's right yeah yeah so you can you
know you can pay for this is it i mean
like a speaker system or something like
that dentists have that [ __ ] as well
like for braces so that that makes sense
there you go so it's not completely out
of
but it's just it's funny like how we how
is it taken like 2021
finally there's big dick surgery yeah
it's wild how long has this taken dog
you know what this works for us though
give it a couple years then you're gonna
get all the women going
off just can't trust anyone anymore all
these guys
they get the pnuma thing and you can
tell you can tell
but you know what it's done for me it's
kind of ruined big dicks for me
yeah same same it's just like
it's not you know lately i've been
looking for men they're a little bit
smaller
yeah yeah i like the more natural look
it just feels more confident
yeah exactly just a little bit more
trustworthy they just own what they have
and now we're going full roman and
that's when we're gonna get
the the renaissance period of the tiny
penis
of the laying on top of the balls yeah
dick yeah yeah yeah
cut like a little cocoon just like a
nice nice cushion it's like a hammock
yeah shredded as [ __ ] with the smallest
dick ever
that's gonna be the ideal look that's
going to be the ideal look
i mean i'm living in the wrong wrong
generation yeah amanda can take care of
you
build a a fortress and
but doesn't have a bolt-on willy no has
an all-natural willy
yeah i don't need this big fake dick
it's just it was just
whatever you know fake real it all just
starts to
just starts to be meaningless
like oh great another big dick what
about some personality
it's like sure it looks good in pants
but it's just it doesn't hang the same
[Laughter]
yeah plus i'm getting older and just
doing the whole thing it's just
a lot harder and i mean those panumas i
mean my god
i i you know what i want to know if
maybe someone who listens to us has
gotten it maybe
you know dudes i'd like to know you know
what come on next week
[Music]
yeah we should have someone on next week
that has had it
and we could talk to him about the
recovery did you lose length did you and
we're all gonna be like this
yeah he's gonna be ear to ear with that
or with that
[ __ ] eating grin yep dick's [ __ ] huge
now doubled in size
it's uh it's guys i don't want to
sugarcoat it it's
[ __ ] massive
i got a big old dong now guys and i and
i i
can't even really be humble about it
because there's no reason to be i have a
big ass dick it's
[ __ ] huge i don't think i've worn
underwear since i've got this thing
yeah all i wear are compression shorts
it's amazing what you get by within this
world with the panuma and some
compression shorts man
yeah i got a new audi r8 i didn't pay
for it
this one in the dealership everyone
jumped back holy [ __ ]
look at that guy's dick get him a car
fast one now
oh my god look at his dick oh my god
oh i wish my husband had your [ __ ]
that's not a penis that's a [ __ ]
and now i ride down the street blasting
pneumonium a
yeah i mean dude
what okay
what you're you're in the middle of a
pandemic
you're working remote you get a new car
and you dick
you saying which one do you get yeah
you don't need a new car that's what
you're saying right yeah i'm saying
there's no reason
we're at home all the time new
new dick new deck i got a new dick
yeah and it'd be for me
you know i'm getting it for me you know
you know wait for it bro
all the um women in rap that's gonna be
so it's gonna be their new bars
by my man a new dick you know like the
way every rapper talks about buying
their girl tits and [ __ ]
buy my man a new dick and wrap me up i
can't wait to
till we can get dick shots yeah she
bossed him up she made him get a big
dick to blow her [ __ ] out
yeah yeah i liked his personality i
liked who he was but i needed that big
dick so i
made him get one now i got a man of
personality and he blows my back out and
i
made him like that yeah
it's bought him some like bought him
some
gucci shoes get him out of the
flip-flops
you know bought him a new thing
gave him dick shots
i mean you know yeah i mean i could keep
going
yeah but you know
i could i was like nah please don't
please don't don't
dog yeah you know i like i said i'm
gonna give it a few years i'ma see if
anyone dies from it
you know what kind of [ __ ] when they
when they
introduce battery operation inside
that's when i'm getting it
what do you mean oh like uh vibrate mode
and and
when my [ __ ] can be a mobile sybian
yeah i mean not only that you could have
like a
full-on like animatronic dick yeah you
know oh if i can be playing
games on my phone and that thing is just
doing the work
you know if i'm just like wait what do
you mean you know liam's like i wanna
hold on babe
and i just like
i'll just give i just give elena like a
bluetooth controller that looks
it looks like this is a little joystick
and she's just sitting on the top riding
it like a little ride
[Laughter]
ah wait it's bugging out i don't know
what's happening it's bugging out
slapping your thighs
just salmoning your own thighs i don't
know what's happening
damn it ah
get in there it's [ __ ]
it's gotta be going so fast you can't
even you can't even see it it's just a
blur
yeah you just [ __ ]
got it got it got it got it take the
battery out the battery out stay down
stay down got to reset it hold on hold
on
ah there goes
[Laughter]
animatronic deck damn
you